[Music]
we'll have three funerals that we're
gonna have to deal with once the fire
situation is sorted itself out but until
that time we've just got to keep on
going what's he doing you know because I
mean not consulting the Queen er'ka
somebody's father I mean only at
Balmoral and not that far but that
reason I am glad that luxury exists and
that people are around who are prepared
to spend the money he's to wash his
hands all the time when I asked my dad
you know why describe their wishes hands
it's it's because he remembers the mud
of the trenches he could never get his
hands clean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the bushfire crisis in Australia
where police have confirmed the death of
a 71 year old man bringing the number of
people killed to 25
[Applause]
fires are still burning in parts of all
states and territories in Australia in
New South Wales around 1,500 homes have
been destroyed in the past month alone
these firefighters are making sacrifices
on a daily basis and none more so than
the family of Nathan bonden his uncle
and cousin both died trying to save
their home but still he's on the
bushfire front lines we went with the
volunteer as he travelled around the
Baker Valley assessing the most recent
damage his family hasn't even had the
funerals yet doing his bit for the
community seems to be what's getting him
through this all we had a job to do we
had to continue doing that I think after
we told my mom it was probably still
another six or seven maybe eight hours
before we got back to her to physically
see her and we had to keep going because
there was a community that was depending
on us to make the right decisions and to
be in the right frame of mind to keep
protecting them and you know we had a
job to do and we had to keep doing it
and every day since we've got up and
we're throwing the uniform on my dad and
my brother and myself and we've
continued to go out there because it's
just what you do it's the right thing to
do and
my older brothers come home to help me
with my mum and at some point soon we'll
you know we'll have to plan some
funerals and you have to top it all off
my grandmother passed away the next day
at the same same side of the family and
and so we'll have three funerals that
we're gonna have to deal with once the
fire situation is sorted itself out but
until that time we've just got to keep
on going because that's the only option
we have aren't you scared
Nathan especially when it's so up close
and personal yeah I'm scared about what
might happen to you of course I am but I
think any firefighter who says they're
not scared is his um you know is its
line he's lying to you because fear is
what makes you make the right decisions
if you're afraid then you're being safe
and you're finding the right things to
you know to keep going and the only
thing I can take from you know losing
losing my family is that we can help
others not go through what our family is
going through and that's why I put the
uniform back on every day and that's why
my dad does and my brother does and why
we keep going because if we can make
sure that no one else has to feel what
my family and what my auntie
then I've done my job
[Music]
my
this latest announcement that they want
to break the mold and step away from
being senior oils has caused real
turmoil within the royal family
[Music]
Arthur Edwards has observed the Royals
close up for years as the roll
photographer for the some thrilled to
say that he's with us here in this year
how he okay
hi surprised me I suppose there was
shocked
rather than surprised I kind of felt
this was going to be coming you know
when they went off for six weeks to
America I've never known a member real
family just takes six weeks off like
that and and hop off to to another
country and and during that time we
never had a peep from him there was not
one paparazzi picture there was not one
story but when I win it when I read that
email last night oh my god I thought
what's he doing you know because I mean
not consulting the Queen er'ka
somebody's father I mean or only at
Balmoral they're not that far and I
suggest a hurry that he gets on a plane
and goes up and sees his grandmother and
his father and and sort this out
Megan's implants well I think so I mean
I know Harry was like before he was a
fantastic person you go to a hospital in
hospital Barbados he would have all the
kids laughing and smile in and and and
he was an incredible person to work with
and I still feel that he's got more to
offer but maybe he's got to go there
maybe he's got to give it a try at
Megan's way and I something to marriage
sometimes you have to give and take than
you and if she wants to give that a go
well fine but you know there's only so
many up for a win for shows you can do
so many speeches you can give and I
think it's the I think it's the biggest
shock since Diane I gave that interview
on panorama when that shot the nation
shot me anyway and I thought I knew it
all but I didn't it's a shame a shame he
can recover it by going up and seeing
her majesty I think I think you can I
think it I think and I think that would
be the right thing to do certainly the
Queen is very wise and his father who
you know will probably try and help him
as much as he can for in Styles as you
know he's he said a terrific last year
you know with these documentaries and
and the fact that he is you know his
approval ratings risen but he will be
SARP set for this bliss lad he won't be
angry he won't he won't
pareja suneel time counselling luxury
carmaker rolls-royce has celebrated a
record year in 2019 up 25% on the year
before even though the latest models
would set you back around half a million
pounds a business correspondent Paul
Kelso had a rare chance to travel in one
accompanied by the chief executive of
the company who like the British
companies owners happens to be German
[Music]
how much is one of these gonna set me
back easy half a million I would say
depends on what you are commissioning
with us we are famous for bespoke as you
know yeah and your wish is our command
and whatever comes we are prepared to
build for you the world is changing
either a future for this kind of really
we would use the word luxury but this is
excessive this cost more than a house
this costs me two times the average
house 20 times the average salary is
this kind of spending sustainable I
think so I think nothing wrong with it
and it's not only about let's say us
doing that I think we should be glad
that we have the luxury industry in the
world because luxury is good for your
soul it is something that is quite
inspiring something you hardly see on
every single street corner it fulfills
personal dreams it satisfies to a
certain point don't forget we are
putting over two thousand people into
work we are the biggest employer here in
West Sussex in the UK so for that reason
I think it's great that was royce has
such a great reputation and also
successful Dwight it's fantastic for the
British industry and for the British
economy and it's fabulous also for yeah
improving so many people for that reason
I am glad that luxury exists and that
people are around who are prepared to
spend the money on luxury goods and it's
not only cars it's jewellery
it's watches it's fashion I think this
entire market of luxury is pretty much
growing over the next year's if it's
good for the soul the spending because
they run out of things to spend money on
I mean it's it I'm not saying that this
is the only thing that pleases yourself
of course not but I think also you need
to see that many of our
are hardworking and they have also done
quite a lot for the economy as I told
you 80 percent of our customers are
businessmen and businesswomen putting
again many people into work so they are
the drivers of the economy in many many
countries worldwide for that reason I
think it's fine for me it's fair for me
if they do extra achievements and have
extra achievements in their life why not
spending some of your own money it's
been cracking jokes on TV and radio for
decades now and Frank Skinner is now to
take his comedy to London's West End I
think if you watched us every one of our
really bad Rao's it would be like what
in a band in concert because we start
off with some new stuff
[Music]
and then we then we start rolling out at
brightest here
problem is that a lot of us are so so
old we can't remember 2009 and lovely to
have you here Frank you joining us and
you've done so much over your career
already but but not the West End this is
extraordinary no I haven't done a lot of
proper Westerner on before we'd stand up
so it's quite exciting she get you know
you get your picture outside the theater
and all that you see I'm I'm somewhere
for one night and then I'm gone and now
I'll be able to put pitch yourself in my
dressing room and stuff like that which
is great I can bring the spittoon you've
you've got this great radio career going
on you've also obviously done TV written
songs what is it you prefer doing the
most well I do like stand-up because
that's what I started doing and I've
noticed that when I write stand-up I do
it with a biro and and a school because
that's how I started I didn't have I
remember my first word process that was
quite a moment so yeah it really feels
like back to basics with it I though the
radio is a joyous thing as well and you
say you write it with a biro Frank how
much of it is scripted how much of it is
improvised as you go along depending on
how the audience are reacting to you
well yeah I mean I build the scaffolding
but a lot of the bricks appear that
night so I can be talking to someone
who's got an unusual job or just call
something out and that sends the whole
thing going somewhere else which is the
most exciting part of it you know is it
exciting having a live audience how do
you deal with the hecklers and have
thick as your skin I think you should
have one on this show volunteer if you
have an audience be very tempting to put
the good news at the front to get them
on your side first and then and then
tell them about that the attacks in our
ears all the time no I think heckling is
a part of the whole thing and I I
embrace it I don't do those put down
lines in the Royals are in your in your
set no no no of course the big wrong use
today is it giving you loads of new
material
I hope so I'm fascinated by it I'm gonna
make if it lasts long I open on
one day and I'm open it there's still
relax just sense isn't it that they've
come back you know when you come back
from holiday and you think oh I had this
with my seven-year-old the other night I
want to go back to school can't we stay
on holiday and I think that's what Harry
and make it me coming through
also there I think it's tough being a
ginger in the royal family I mean in a
seraph I held him back I see him getting
a Hollywood actress I think when he goes
only the corgis will be left on the
ginger frog you've once they've got a
young royal fan and in Prince George
yeah well so um so he's dad told me I
did the Royal Variety and he said that
his son Joey said to me George plays
your and football song every morning and
I really wanted to say Who and he said
yes so every morning in wherever they
live chanting one of the one another
palace yeah yeah he's blasting out three
lines which is us I was very pleased
about it it's an interesting debate
about royalties from royalty
[Music]
they're continuing rising tensions
between Iran and the u.s. is putting
negotiations between Tehran and the
United Kingdom over detainees at risk
sherry is Audi's husband Anushka Sheree
was sentenced to 10 years in prison last
year after a round found him guilty of
spying for the Israeli intelligence
agency so you're allowed to talk to him
for what 20 minutes a day something yes
on the phone how does the conversation
go between the two of you the
conversations obviously you know
sometimes that it's quite personal but
you're always aware that someone is
listening to your conversation so it's
sometimes it's very difficult to be just
yourself you know you have to be on your
guard all the time but with this
escalation everybody's feeling extremely
low I think the chances of anybody
reaching an agreement seem is very far
away now what impact I was having on you
it's it's very difficult sometimes
because you feel like you're carrying
the burden of the whole family on your
shoulder and there's so many things to
juggle there's you know there's work
there's home there's I mean my children
are growing up but obviously they're
still my children and generally it's
it's it's it's difficult to stay
positive but what else can you do you
have to go on and have to put a brave
face on it we know that number 10
watches the program what would you like
to say to the prime minister I would
like to tell him to please do everything
possible to get them out especially in
view of the recent situation because
sometimes they it it doesn't feel safe
where they are because a couple of
occasions some guards had told not just
my husband but a couple of other dual
nationals that we don't really see why
they keep you alive here you're all a
bunch of spies you're a bunch of
traitors
and if it were up to us some of us we
would just take machine gun and kill
y'all but obviously you know they're not
allowed but when something like this
happens you know when a major figure
heroic figure in Iran like ceremony is
killed
obviously the backlash is immediately on
the people that they perceived to be
sympathetic to his killers which
includes us which includes you you you
know for the UK so I really would like
the Prime Minister to to double to
triple his effect you know his efforts
please do do something the Olympics
might happen every four years but it's
taken a hundred and twenty four years
for rock climbing to become a part of it
[Music]
Britain's most successful climber Shana
clock see now needs to get to grips with
the format it still seems really strange
to hear people say that climbing is
gonna be in the Olympics and then to
think about being part of the Olympics
as an athlete is yeah it's so surreal
I think climbing was growing already and
it was kind of growing at this rate that
I never expected so with the Olympic
announcement that's kind of snowboard
that which yeah it's really crazy to
hear people you know on the tube
chatting about climbing and then
everywhere you go people know about the
sport now I feel like more and more I'm
not having to explain what climbing is
but talk about it and yeah people are
really interested in it now
I actually saw someone free climbing so
climbing without ropes a lady called
Katherine dusty Bell on the TV when I
was three years old I remember turning
to my dad and being like I want to do
that yeah which I guess is quite not
very normal for a little kid
we saw watch the adventure programs all
the time and I loved it and then
climbing just stuck in my brain and we
found the local climbing wall about a
year later
I want to get to Tokyo fit healthy happy
strong and if I can do that then I
definitely feel like I can compete for a
medal but with climbing it's not a sport
where you directly compete against
anyone else I guess a little bit in
speed but in Boulder and lead it's you
in the wall you all you can control is
your own performance so yeah I want to
be able to give my best performance and
if that's worthy of a medal then that'd
be amazing but yeah I just want to get
there and be ready to compete there's
only one way this ends
with a wad seasoned firmly underwear the
first world war epic 1917 has already
won two Golden Globes and picked up nine
BAFTA nominations written and directed
by Sam Mendes it's an epic but also very
personal tale inspired by stories his
grandfather told him when he was a boy
about his own experiences of the First
World War
I think clearly they stayed with me all
these years I mean I must have been
about 11 or 12 so it was 40 years ago
and I suppose it was a combination of
things it was a very jovial man so it
seemed really odd that he had been
through these hellish experiences but he
hadn't talked about that for 50 or 60
years and he only told Balan with his
grandchildren really used to wash his
hands all the time and I asked my dad
you know why does grant I wash his hands
he says because he remembers the mud of
the trenches and he could never get his
hands clean and that really struck me as
well that it was still in his body was
in his every fiber of his being almost
unconsciously
even though it would have been so long
ago so they yeah they stayed with me he
told one particular story about carrying
a message through no-man's land in the
in the in the mist a dusk that that was
the little fragment that kept pulling at
me and when I finally sat down to write
screenplay I found that that was the
story I wanted to tell but to take that
and expand it develop it into something
that perhaps a little bit more epic
you want it to be immersive you know and
you want to make it feel as if the
audience's is with an alongside these
actors and experiencing time with the
characters you know just feeling every
second passing taking every step with
them and understanding geography and
distance and difficulty and all those
things you said it just feels different
when you know you're not going to cut
out you're not going to jump 100 yards
you're not going to see us on God shot
and see what they can't see
you can only ever see what they can see
sometimes you can't even see that I hope
there might be a good day
pretty much every day at some point I
thought why have I done this myself it
would be so much easier to make this in
a conventional way you know but when you
get the shot and these are long long
takes it's so exhilarating and so
exciting that you just want to do it
again so you know it just sort of kept
regenerating and and once you commit to
it you know it begins to be a challenge
that you feel like I'm not going to give
up until I've got this it's very
important and very personal and I'm very
proud of it but you know I suppose it
feels like a culmination of some of the
stuff I was doing in the Bond movies you
know and it's sort of epic cinematic
scale but at the same time a combination
of some of the stuff I'm doing the
theater you know because for me it's not
unusual to do a two-hour story without
someone saying cut you know because
that's what you know it's what I do with
most of the time anyway
so it feels like a very particular
marriage of all those different things
which is never really happened before
you